let me tell you this the older you do
get more rules are gonna try to get you
to follow you just gotta keep living man
l-i-v-i-n
[Music]
[Applause]
all right all right all right
44 versions of the movie and soundtrack
55 Promotional and memorabilia items
over 250 individual items my name is
Garth boes and I've got the largest
daising infused collection in the
country
[Music]
welcome to movie people the show where
we share the incredible true stories of
passionate fans whose favorite films or
filmmakers made a huge impact on their
lives I'm a big believer every movie has
a super fan and sure enough I had no
trouble tracking down someone with a
deep passion for a classic celebrating
its 30th Anniversary Dazed and Confused
so deep in fact that he's amassed a
massive collection of memorabilia that's
someone Garth Bose a husband and father
of three from Huntersville North
Carolina who claims to have the largest
Dazed and Confused collection in the
entire country so naturally I had to
check it out
this is one of my favorite things so
this is actually still frames from the
still photographer that was on set
during the movie filming and then it
flips into head shots and resumes for
all of you you have their resumes in
here this is an unused cardboard VHS
case Okay Garth I need to know how all
of this began
so right after it come out on VHS rental
I would have been 14. then I went out
and and purchased it and once I owned my
own copy that went with me everywhere
there was a handful of versions of the
movie in the soundtrack and then I I
bought a car
all right all right all right we
actually find a Chevelle and I spent the
next uh two years rebuilding it and
painting it to look exactly like
wooderson's Chevelle from the movie and
you teach me how to change my Mini
Cooper into a Jurassic Park SUV please
how do I do that I can figure that out
all right let's see it I need to know
what's behind that door behind the
locker here that's a lot
[Music]
foreign
the top question on my list though is
why are they hidden in a cabinet and not
displayed it's a lot of stuff and my
wife has a certain aesthetic that she
goes for in the home I respect her
I have a beautiful home but I have some
suggestions okay
that's I mean much better if we do
enough of this and she comes back into
the room and she might give you the okay
I might need some help selling it but
yeah I think so let's do it
[Music]
this would be a Hollywood Video rental
version this is vcd from Hong Kong this
is their version of how the movie was
released so this is an actual 35
millimeter reel of the trailer of the
movie it's one of my all-time favorite
pieces uh the riaa certified sales award
for half million coffees this is amazing
what a crazy cool thing to have for such
an iconic soundtrack this is the exact
same model of headphones Kmart
headphones that Mitch uses at the end of
the movie
oh wow I am a big pop collector and it's
blowing my mind right now popped and
confused he's an artist and so once he
did one and I was able to get that from
him I just sort of said hey if you're
going to make the rest of them or you
would like to make the rest of them I'm
in and the detail was just amazing so
these are a little bit on the rare sides
everything is signed and everything's a
one-on-one this piece was actually owned
by Adam F Goldberg the creator of the
television series The Goldbergs how much
do they go oh it was a lot for 3 300
bucks or something like that I think
somewhere around there I need to know
what those checks back there are those
are an interesting tie the whole premise
of the movie is based around getting to
Aerosmith we're going Aerosmith there
was actually an Aerosmith show that
Richard was basining around that
happened in 76 in Dallas so this is the
check and a ticket stub used for that
and this is the actual check from the
bank like the real deal check this is
the real stamped by the bank check paid
to Aerosmith
[Music]
oh that looks great just to make this
absolutely official now I need I need
firm yes or no yes does it stay or no
does it have to go
it has to go you can move all that stuff
into your garage
there's a lot of pressure so I guess you
get the wrong house
okay I'm impressed is this your
handiwork or did someone help you with
it it is not so this is a local artist I
hired who does murals she paints walls
sides of buildings all kinds of stuff
like that and
these are numbered paddles there's a
there's an artist that builds these she
created them originally and so they're
all replicas uh and they all have
numbers on the handles so nice I do
notice like another pattern happening or
a sub theme a very specific one might
have something to do with all this the
judge yeah well I mean there is one more
piece that we can show you can I see it
like right now yeah we can take you
there we gotta go for a drive though
yes please I'm not gonna say no to that
yeah let's go okay let's do it
[Music]
so here it is dude that's the coolest
thing it's perfect
[Music]
it is just absolutely stunning thank you
it's missing a key component but that's
why it's here it doesn't run without
them no oh I don't know anything about
cars this is pickford's car yep why this
particular car I was probably more like
Anthony more of like the ancillary
friend out on the outside but Pickford
was was it the car the hair that was who
I wanted to be you know I had the cool
factor in the ink chair and everything
else just sort of going on for him this
is clearly the biggest of the bun yeah
it's the largest piece it's the most
valuable obviously to probably the most
important one to me it's a part of the
family it has a name it has an Instagram
page
so nice this is incredible I want to be
very respectful asking this question
while I'm sitting in this particular car
because it's a gorgeous car but is there
a a level up like another Edition that
you have in mind the answer is yes
there's always one obviously the big
white whale is to get the movie car to
get to own a car that was screen used
and that's that that's proved to be a
bit challenging I did a bunch of
research because there are two of them
and one of the cars all we had was a
person's first name from there I got in
touch with the owner and I flew out
about a year ago to California and they
were super great took me for a drive in
it
and that was super special for me in its
own right just just to be there and be
in its presence I would have loved to
have left with it uh but you know
they're not ready to let it go
what is it like just sitting there and
enjoying this world that you love so
much it's super exciting it's fun to
even just with you guys get to go
through all this stuff again relive it
all this whole 30th Anniversary stuff
just reinvigorates everything it's
forced me to watch the movie all over
again and start it again what advice
would you give someone else if they
wanted to start a collection that could
turn out to be like yours don't be
afraid to dig deep and don't be afraid
to just reach out to someone that you
think might be able to help you the
community of movie memorabilia or is
excited to talk about this stuff and
Lead You In A Direction than anybody
else is going to be so well I appreciate
you sharing your collection with us
really nothing fills my heart more than
to meet other people who love movies as
much as I do I am going to keep my
fingers crossed the car dream comes true
but in the meantime
well it's 30th anniversary celebration
right there very cool very cool I think
this has got to go right on we're going
to open it we're going to open it okay
let's put it on let's put it where it
belongs
[Music]
perfect perfect awesome